[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 150 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm ma Crandall and I'm here has always
with my colleague Melanie how you doing
Melanie hi mark I'm good how are you I'm
very well what is this this is a hundred
and fifty 150
I know it's amazing right I know I was
actually trying to work out when you
first came on the podcast and I couldn't
work it out I started helping you at the
beginning of November so we're almost
out of here we're almost a year that's
pretty good did you put up with me for a
year I know it's kind of amazing yeah
and it's been almost three years since
she started the podcast it's true your
first episode you came on was 93 what
say I with Melanie worried true y'all
did interview me but I actually started
helping you in November when princess
took off anyway so mark what do we have
for this week so we have some cool stuff
for this week we have a very good
virtual friend of ours KF who has a long
history of working in the software
engineering industry doing distributed
systems and kind of all the things I
feel like and is the reason we know each
other in the first place as well she's
definitely the reason we know each other
and it's an interview that I've been
wanting us to do for a while now so I'm
really glad we finally got a chance to
talk to her and we were able to do that
actually at a conference where we did
meet also which is strange Luke a great
conference it's out of st. Louis so
we'll get into that in the interview but
yeah I'm glad we finally got a chance to
get her on here yeah exactly
and so after we talk to her we will have
our question of the week as we do always
which is how do I encrypt and decrypt
data with cloud key management services
which is something I've not looked at
before but it's actually kind of cool
definitely and as we always do we're
gonna start out with cool things of the
week and for this week we've got a lot
of support and integration going on with
pi torch which is a platform that's used
for building out neural nets similar
trends flow it's just a different
platform and so pi torch we now have
integrated so there's actually on Google
cloud platform you know deep learning VM
images that you can implement it's also
been integrated already in coop flow but
there's additional support specifically
because PI torch has also launched 1.0
so you can use that on TCP you can use
it with coop flow you can use it
actually also with tensor board
and there's work in progress they're
piloting some stuff around the cloud
tape use and using PI torch so we'll
post the article for that you can check
them out nice since we're talking about
cue flow and kubernetes we want to
mention I wanted a little article called
a developer on ramp to kubernetes with
gke I thought this was really nice in
that it's a set of tools specifically
for making it easier more affordable to
run small krupa Nettie's clusters
basically up to four nodes or less than
four nodes if you want so if you're if
you're trying to set up a small
developer environment we actually have
some documentation and a developer
template set up as well as the new york
and source utility called cue post to
get around some of the toss things that
happen with Humanity's it can be a
little bit more expensive if you want to
run a big cluster so this is just a some
nice tooling to get you started in a
nice low cost way and another cool thing
of the week we want to mention is
network controls and GCP versus
on-premises this is a blog post that our
friend Grace has posted it's great
suggestion with Jenn's coolers which I'm
probably watching winning but this
article in particular is sort of walking
you through the fact that network
controls in GCP are not that different
necessarily from on-premises so you
wouldn't have to do a significant amount
of additional understanding I guess or
work to understand the two and they talk
through like subnets and rats and
firewalls and VPN yeah and lost
definitely not least I feel like every
time we turn around there's a new
article by our teammate Sarah Robinson I
don't know that's I do too she's
generally producing a lot of good
content absolutely so she has another
great article talking about Auto ml but
in this case it's talking about Auto ml
translate which is really kind of
interesting it talks about how and why
you might need Auto male power translate
capabilities so the example that they
use is like for example using the word
driver like if you're playing golf
driver means one thing but if you need a
taxi driver means something else but if
you're in the software context driver
means yet another thing and so you might
need something like auto ml to be able
to do translations that are
domain-specific yes and she steps you
through an example that she's built out
specifically with Auto ml Translate and
also using something known as we
localize which is it's one of the
largest localization providers in the US
with a mission to help the customers
localized content for global audiences
so you can check out her article and see
how to use Google Auto ml translate
awesome well why don't we go have a chat
with KF yes
should definitely go dr. cat it'll be
fun I'm very happy we have with us today
KF who is a good friend of both of ours
and this is the reason why mark and I
actually know each other so KF thank you
very much for coming on the podcast
today sure can tell us a little bit
about who you are yeah what do you do
I yes and why do we know you do
computers vaguely excellent I do some
combination of like back-end and data
and infrastructure things primarily at
startups and data science things I would
not describe myself as a data scientist
describe myself as an engineer with a
math degree we were noting before we
start recording you did hold the title
at one point of data scientist I'm not
sure that startup titles count so we're
recording this as strangelets you do
business conferences actually where I
met mark because of KF and I met KF
because we both went through the same
coding boot camp not together but we met
because of it which was really oh you
went through at different times I didn't
know but anyway so KF how's the
conference going for you it's good it is
mostly I this is my sixth year coming so
everytime I come back it's like fewer
and fewer talks I go to at the
conference and more just sort of walking
around attempting to go to a talk as
people stopped me on the way and
actually what is strange loop I don't
really know I think when I started
coming it was mostly because there were
talks on functional programming that was
not necessarily the talks I go do you
know at all I feel like it's like this
weird mix of bleeding edge ish computer
science wacky interesting tech stuff
philosophy diversity inclusion and
social political issues mushed into one
big thing that seems like it's cool and
interesting yeah and it's been going on
for 10 years Alex who's the original
person who drove and developed all this
he's doing a little retrospective back
on when it started I think it was like
300 people with the first one and now
it's like around 2200 people for this
one yeah based in st. Louis so you don't
know but you love it and you got a good
Network here what were some of the
highlights from today and yesterday so
far for you I spent
most of the past day enough going to
talks about tech related to social good
which is not something that they had
talks on whenever I first started coming
it was more like recent years given the
political atmosphere that they start
being introduced so Bridgette who's one
of the other organizers who I know from
doing closure stuff she put together a
pre-conference day that was the whole
day yesterday that was unlike people who
work on tools related to like nonprofits
and helping the government and
environmental issues and things like
that so any cool stuff that we keep take
away and potentially tell our listeners
I think the most actionable talk yeah it
was probably the one from the guy who
started Ruby for good oh cool gave a
talk about how to get more involved with
like nonprofits and why you should do
that nice in your spare time like
instead of just doing open source
related to things that are technically
interesting doing open source related to
things that are useful to people outside
of the tech industry you into that talk
oh nevermind you went to a different
talk on open source that was today I did
Evan who started out his last name I can
never pronounce did a really interesting
talk on dealing with being an
open-source maintainer and dealing with
like people coming up and being like LM
is going to die and like how do you
handle that as an open-source maintainer
but also like actions that could be
taken to potentially turn that into a
more positive statement and like curta
fie the sort of conversations that
should happen inside that environment
and he tied it back to a whole bunch of
like philosophical and sociological
stuff that came previously with like
books about that kind of stuff that come
from like the 60s and stuff it was
actually really really good talk nice
mark what got you starting to come to
Strange Loop I usually come here from
Australia regularly I think about six
years ago Wow
so you've been here for six years as
well something like that I think I
missed a year somewhere in between I'm
trying to remember I think I had a
friend who was coming or I saw it and I
was like that just looks awesome
and I need to be at that conference and
so I started I think it was a short
answer and then I was like this is
amazing
I need to come back it's a conference
that imposes impostor syndrome
[Laughter]
I know but I feel like it's true because
it is an environment in which you're
always going to meet someone who knows
stuff you don't know or you're just
gonna sit in a Tolkien just be like I
have no idea what that is but I feel
like two years down the line if you head
in a certain direction depending on what
it is you'll be like oh I remember that
talk from Strange Loop two years ago
that I saw about someone talking about
something now I know how didn't make
like mathematical models it'll tell me
how to fold origami paper like awesome I
can use that and did you make that I
have not needed that yet but someday you
will okay well if it's imposing the
imposter syndrome are you both coming
back so often I don't know that I have
impostor syndrome working in the tech
industry is being like in many other
jobs in which you just have to
constantly pick up new skills because
capitalism yep I also love to I love to
learn that's a that's a big job seated
like thing that I love a passion so I
know I appreciate that this conference
it seems to be very driven to give
conference talks on knowledge and
sharing knowledge versus like we want to
show you the new yeah it's very much not
a shiner comfort thing but I think he's
still open to people who have beginners
either levels or mindsets yeah whenever
I started coming I had like no
experience program yeah wait is that
like realistically or functionally
realistic like three months of
experience for having or something
ridiculous yeah I'd never done
functional programming before or touched
like anything that didn't mention did
strange loop before I had and the first
year I came it was before they had like
opportunity grants and things which is
one of the things I've always been very
impressed with with this conference in
particular she was such a drive
specifically with opportunity grants and
just making sure that the diversity is
being recognized and built out and if
anything I've seen that evolve and
change it's such a small thing but it's
so true like last year was the first
time I saw a line at the women's
bathroom and it was the first time I've
ever seen a line at the women's bathroom
I was like oh that's awesome
any other highlights from the conference
this year previous years like did y'all
meet at this conference how did we meet
we met through a mutual friend Sean who
you know from when you did cold fusion
[Laughter]
that sounds about right actually and who
I know things
my co fees our programming to actually
to your to your point like we're talking
about like why I was here I feel like we
want to go back through my history
because I don't know why that seems like
a thing we're doing now I think it was
around the time that I'd stopped kind of
doing cold fusion as a thing and was
really trying to expand my horizons and
learn a whole bunch of stuff and
strangely looked like an amazing
opportunity to do that and honestly
continues to be so did strangely inspire
you to get more exposure to distributed
systems distributed computing I think it
sort of came the other way around which
is I got into programming because I was
in grad school for math and for some
assignment my first semester of grad
school I ended up reading research
papers from like research and was
reading something about like clustering
algorithms at YouTube or something and
was like oh this is interesting and then
tried to like learn to program and stuff
and then ended up going to code school
and then once I was there people were
like you seemed to be the kind of person
who enjoys academic papers which means
probably functional programming and
distributed systems are for you and then
you went with it yeah not necessarily a
normal start into programming what is a
normal start into programming
I do know that when I started out doing
programming and could cite a bunch of
academic papers but had no experience in
industry that was deeply unusual and
people did not know how to respond to it
I think it's less bizarre now in part I
think because they have things like
strange loop that have opportunity
grants so it's like not unheard of do
you recommend it as a pathway follow
your bliss also I don't think it's
harder from like a technical perspective
to pick up these things there's nothing
inherent about this area of computer
science or software engineering that I
feel is harder than like doing front-end
for example I think that sometimes
people make it artificially harder
because they think it's harder so they
don't bother to sort of like learn how
to talk about things in a way that's
more approachable versus like does there
exist something that teaches distributed
systems to beginners and this is
- Matic way like the way that there's
girls who code and what are the
nonprofit like yeah there are so many
they at this point where they mean there
are so many the variety you can learn
how to build a she learning application
you you haven't seen anything yet that's
been like introductory Joe I don't think
people see it as being introductory at
all in part because nobody writes
introductory materials where does
distributed computing typically sit
within the structure of an engineering
org from what you've seen in what you've
experienced I tend to get bounced around
between back-end infrastructure platform
type teams and then I sort of fell into
doing data things for a few years like
off and on because a lot of the
languages that I was using to do
platform type stuff we're also starting
to get used for data stuff so like Scala
originally I picked up not for data
stuff I picked it up primarily because
like functional programming in
distributed systems and then that
started becoming a language because of
spark that people were using for data so
then people looked at my resume and
we're like you do data things cuz you
have a math degree and know these
languages which is like not necessarily
accurate though it is no worse in
general but I I remember at one point
you also you've you've had a passion for
closure closure in terms of the
functional programming space that's
clear I appreciate that
yeah so I fell into doing closure not
for work but because I was on a mailing
list and Bridget who's now one of the
co-organizers for strange loop was
putting together workshops to teach
women closure and/or functional
programming through closure and before I
worked in tech I worked in teaching so I
was sort of like if you needed any help
with curriculum development let me know
and then I got involved with it through
that and then eventually despite the
fact that I had not written like almost
any closure in earnest yeah I just
became very strongly associated with it
until it was actually a thing that I did
so I also want to know I'm great
actually
we said distributed computing you like
disputed systems like what does that
mean
you I think that there's a meaning that
it that it holds for me and then there's
the meaning that holds an industry and
what's the deal with what it says to me
like if you're a front-end developer you
have to have ideas about distributed
computing at this point I think when you
talk to people in industry most of the
time what they mean is like you work on
like core platform infrastructure tech
deals does that mean kubernetes Marc
really wants to bring up the kubernetes
perspective because I believe there was
some he was still living in Australia
and did not work for Google and had no
reason to show kubernetes at the time
right it wasn't even necessarily popular
but he was deeply enthusiastic in a way
where I was like why don't you just like
güzel people kubernetes is your job and
became a developer relations person for
kubernetes things and here we are after
giving me grief about it and what do you
think of kubernetes I think it's a tool
and it's a step in the right direction
and I think it helps build better
abstractions in the long term I tend to
think about these things not necessarily
from the perspective of like running
infrastructure for the sake of keeping
things running but more from the idea of
like infrastructure as a product and I
think that becomes easier to build those
kinds of tools when you have something
like kubernetes that becomes a kind of
distraction over things are there any
other tools that you've found our
valuable and the work that you do I mean
there's docker which is just sort of
like at this point also prolific after
like it wasn't when I started and now
after five years it's just like I can't
imagine not using it at this point so I
know we've talked around about the
different things that you've done what
do you enjoy doing in the computing
space I don't know that I enjoy specific
technical things at this point I enjoy
building things that are useful that's
valid because I think you've had kind of
a history of kind of building platforms
that would then be on used by other
areas of companies would that be vaguely
right yeah I haven't done as much
feature development for things that get
used externally
I've done some of that when I work on
those kinds of surfaces it's usually
more from like an SRE perspective where
I'm like trying to make something more
performant for the customer not
necessarily building the initial thing
so so I know you've done the coding
bootcamp you've done some of your own
self-study like what do you think are
some good pathways now and we already
talked about some of the new coding
projects that are out there a little bit
in terms of getting people in but what
do you think are some good ways for
those who are trying to find their
pathway into building out things
building things whatever form that takes
I think all of the options are hard ah I
think there was a period of time where
if you already had a degree or you
couldn't afford to go to college then
coding boot camps were potentially a
really great option if you chose the
right one but now they've been around
for so long and there are so many I
think it's hard to choose one because
there are so many that are potentially
bad and there's no regulation on them if
you don't have experience with software
engineering and you maybe don't know
anyone who does software engineering
which is the kind of person who I think
would go to a coding boot camp it's kind
of impossible to tell whether something
is snake oil or dodge so I say that
coding boot camps exists and some of
them are ok and probably check course
report see if it's decent there are like
more places that are starting to do
apprenticeships which I feel like are
always like the best option if you can
manage to go to school for computer
science that's sort of like always I
think still like the best option but
that's not really realistic for everyone
yeah it wasn't realistic for me so well
actually the keynote this morning at
strange loop was talking about how
important it is for all kids to be
exposed to some type of computer science
or just basically foundational computer
science yeah something along those lines
as well as trying to give ideas to think
outside the box but what do you think
about that in terms of the education of
kids do you think that that's a skill
that definitely needs to be applied
across the board I think that everyone
should have exposure to computer science
yes I think some people take it to a
larger degree and say like everyone
should have so many years of computer
science classes or coding classes in
school I don't agree that that's like
reasonable having worked in schools it's
like there's not enough time already do
you ever think it's like what is the
thing
you're going to take out of the
curriculum to put this in I would
struggle to think of something like a
core subject if you're treating computer
science is a core subject that like is
less important than learning to codes I
would struggle to think of something and
one of the points they were making this
morning too was how it's hard to find
also teachers mmm specifically showing
some numbers in terms of there's less
teachers to be able to provide the
education an incentive zero line for
people with computer science degrees to
not be teachers right and I was thinking
at the time I was like you could line
that up against those who have the
expertise than in the machine learning
space and I'm sure it's even less people
but I guess the question I'd ask is
you've meant heard a number of people
coming into the space do you have any
advice for those who might be thinking
about being mentors who want to help
others getting into the space I think
the main thing is that you should try to
one align yourself with some sort of
nonprofit if you're doing it sort of
systematically there are like coding
boot camps that are for-profit that rely
very heavily on mentors and if the
reason for mentoring people is to help
get more people into the fields I don't
understand the rationale for doing that
at a for-profit school in the same way
that I will sometimes like go give talks
at universities to college students
about computer science if I'm going to
sink a bunch of my time like connecting
with some sort of like organization
that's providing mentorship to people I
tend to go for something that's like
low-cost or free because that's usually
people who need it most like a lot of
people I have met through like going to
conferences or being involved
specifically with like setting up like
Opportunity Grant systems or
volunteering around that I don't know
that this is like advice for people
mentoring so much is like for people who
need help with things is like you'd be
surprised how willing people are to help
you if you just ask them for it most of
the time people will say yes not because
I asked for help but because people ask
me for help and most of the time I say
yes or I like introduce them to someone
who's more able to help them and most of
the time that person says yes I was
gonna say like yeah if you got any
suggestions for people to find mentors I
know that's been that can be tricky
sometimes
yeah just ask the question I asked the
question but also spend some amount of
time upfront trying to figure out like
it's more sort of like go to events in
your area if you have them if you don't
like every job I've gotten I've gotten
through Twitter and like most of the
people who I know who have spent time
with me teaching me things like a
disproportionately large number of those
people I met on Twitter it's more like
go socialize with people I'm originally
from Houston so the advice of like go to
events doesn't apply as strongly as in
some cities as others because there
aren't as many tech events in Houston as
there are even like Portland where I
live or startup your own event and
startup your own community if you can
that takes work but yeah you've got time
yeah it's another way I know I've been
number of people who've done that I know
you know I've talked about this before
but just to be on the same page on this
one the people you've mentored
especially like not everybody has a math
degree not everybody who's coming to the
space necessarily had much experience
with computer science the people that
I've come across and I know for myself
too
would you say that's probably what
you've seen as well yeah because I know
that that can sometimes be an
intimidating factor talking about the
imposter syndrome yeah or I was worth
noting like I mean amongst our peers and
like people I know like I know a variety
people who have degrees but not even
remotely in computer science and
psychology and philosophy and like I
know people who have theatre majors
right who work in computer science
degree was English and then I went back
to school later and got a math degree
technically I have a Bachelor of
multimedia I don't know what that's
where it all so I can use Macromedia
director that's how the games come into
the middle of it I play them well so on
a different note how do you get all your
work done with your cat on your head I
work from home
my cat usually leaves me alone unless
I'm in meetings is that right
how do you make sure you're successful
what you're doing
working remotely because I know that's
something that you typically do yeah
I've always worked remotely or for a
while I worked for a company that was in
Portland while I lived in Portland but
just like never went into you I I think
I started doing remote stuff like from
when I was entry level on which is
unusual because most people aren't
willing to hire people who are
entry-level to work remotely I think it
was mostly a factor of finding support
systems locally or even if not locally
like now all the time I'll like run into
something and I won't really know how to
solve the problem and I'll be like the
tech lead so there's no one else to
solve it for me at work so I end up
going and talking to like people I just
like know from the internet yeah are
people I met in other cities when I was
at conferences or when I lived there
when I worked for a company there and be
like in your network have you run into
this yeah actually and then we do that
to each other that's a really good
question too and just talking about
remote culture and something of like you
said like people don't like to hire
people who are at entry-level firm air
positions like what's a successful way
of bringing in entry-level people from
our positions do you think I don't think
it's a requirement that people have
previous professional experience to work
remotely as part of their first job
because I've worked with entry-level
people who had never really had a job
before and were remote in like other
time zones other countries and it worked
out fine I do think though that it is
helpful to like set them up with a
specific person who can like walk them
through like a one-on-one what that
looks like
yeah like you should do that anyway what
starting a job but like even more so
with remote stuff especially if you can
find someone who's been doing remotes
for like a while and it helps to be very
explicit about like what your day looks
like and what other people's days look
like so when I started working remotely
I did not actually have industry
experience before that I'd only ever
worked in schools so I did not
understand what it was like to work in
an office right so I had this I didn't
understand that there were like times of
the day when people went up to go get
coffee or like walk down the street to
get coffee even and that was like a 20
min
break right there so I had this like
weird notion that I needed to be sitting
at my computer all the time oh wow or
like and I needed to put in like eight
hours a day and I also brilliant for
what like eight hours a day of like
earnest coding not like working which
and then a break yeah like now I
understand that working involves many
things such as like talking to people
when I search I didn't understand this
and I would just anchor myself to my
computer for eight hours a day minimum
and code things and I remember
co-workers would try to like encourage
me to get lunch right which is the thing
you should do but also I was entry-level
and it was like my first office quota
met job you can't look around and see
other people modeling like how did you
think so you have to be very explicit
about like this is how I conduct my day
you could also do it these other ways
but this is how I do it how do you
conduct your day so I usually start
working by 9:30 which means I get up at
9:00 at the earliest sometimes and then
I shower and have breakfast or whatever
I usually work from home in the morning
because I don't like commuting during
rush hour times yeah so unless I'm
biking I will work from home in the
morning and then I'll take lunch at
around noon to 1:00 so I'll eat lunch
and then commute into a co-working space
and then I will work from the co-working
space for the rest of the afternoon and
then come home whenever like about eight
hours of working hasn't accomplished or
until like sometimes I have a mindset
that I'm in and I just like don't want
to stop so I'll keep working until I
finish the thing I'm doing adjust yes
yeah we've gone down this remote stuff
which I actually really enjoy because
something needs to do to I'd love to
also hear about like how do you find
like good communication patterns in like
remote teams like things tend to be
asynchronous not everyone's awake at the
same time do you have thoughts unlike
either technology or patents or like
workplace standards I don't know I try
to look for people who enjoy talking
when I interview I try to see if they're
like reasonably talkative if they have
an online presence that's like one way
to tell if they like tend to talk a lot
and stuff online
despite working remotely for like the
entire time I've worked in tech I am NOT
a very like insular person and I jumped
you're shocking shocking I know
I have a few tweets out there so I try
to find workplaces where people aren't
completely siloed and they still talk to
each other all the time throughout the
day I'm like comically referred to it as
like like when I start new job I'm
joining a new slack and do you do you
feel like you almost have to be more
vocal in some ways being remote kind of
have to pusher your personality in your
communication out more than you would
say if you're in an office because of
the distance I have experienced this
especially with people who are starting
out and they're like relatively junior
and they are working remotely for the
first time or something if you're in an
office and you have a junior dev who is
like struggling you can usually tell
that they're struggling because they
look stressed and they haven't moved for
like hours versus if they're remote you
have no idea unless you constantly ping
them or unless they become very direct
and tell you that this is happening
which is like extremely unlikely that
they will do this unless you set up that
report in advance so yes
and then a lot of gifts animated gifts
and a more general note what do you
value most in the companies that you
work for I try to find people who are
different from me who are sufficiently
different from me that I'm not just
stagnating as a person I think a lot of
people look for jobs where you're
picking up a new tech stack and and
pushing yourself in that regard I try to
find companies where they're open tiring
junior does where not everyone is white
where not everyone is a man where there
are queer people where there are people
with disabilities especially because if
you hire a remote I feel like a lot of
companies miss the part about how that
kind of environment can be like when
it's set up correctly like give people
really great job opportunities because
people who are disabled or generally
deeply unemployed yeah
so what so this is great and I just
wanted to say is there anything else
that you wanted to talk about around
strange loop around working remotely
around you know kubernetes
where you're gonna be next
not particularly
okay thank you for spending time with us
today as always spending time with you
as a pleasure but it was lovely having
out recording this time yes thank you
for coming on the podcast actually well
one last thing who would you recommend
should consider coming to test range so
if you're into functional programming
distributed systems security type things
this is probably a good conference to go
to
not necessarily like you've done them
where you've been doing them but like if
you were just interested in them I think
that's sufficient to come let's get
dinner okay thank you again for coming
on the podcast I'm so glad we were able
to make that work yeah me too really
great to have you on actually I went and
had a look a Melanie you started with us
an episode 102 so two more episodes an
year at 50 episodes three tomorrow and
I'm done yeah you were you came on to do
smart parking and IOT core with Brian
granite ear the rappers together for
that yeah and the smart parking was a
really interesting one taehui I know we
resurfaced that with some articles that
he wrote a while back but yeah good
times good time smart well so let's get
into the question of the week yeah which
is not about when did I start anyway the
question the week how do I encrypt and
decrypt data with cloud key management
service yeah I think this is actually
really interesting I was kind of just
poking around looking for a question of
the week and I've never looked at cloud
key management service but basically
it's a cloud hosted key management
service that lets you manage
cryptographic keys for your cloud it's
actually really cool so there's a couple
of possible link to about basically
doing encryption and decryption I am NOT
a security expert so I'm gonna try and
read this as much as possible but I
think I'm not a doctor I'm not a doctor
exactly
please report to neurosurgery and or7
I'm not a lawyer none of those things
but the client API is as well as the
g-cloud tools support both symmetric and
asymmetric encryption so I get the Surat
symmetric algorithms use the same key
for both encryption and decryption
whereas asymmetric algorithms use
different keys for encryption and
decryption and there are different
reasons for using one over the other
it's really quite straightforward to do
the encryption and decryption basically
you're specifying like your location
your keyring your key and then you sort
of specify the text you want to encrypt
it kind of spits it back and then to
decrypt it it's basically doing the same
thing all over again
and all of those keys are managed by
cloud key management service which is
kind of neat and very similarly for yeah
the RSA V asynchronous one asymmetric
where it's a hard
and there's also examples there for
different languages as well go Java
Python for the asymmetric and like see
chef ko Chow and rjs Python Ruby PHP or
just from your command line yeah you can
do it too it's actually really
straightforward I was super impressed
great well mark we're gonna be in the
next couple weeks next couple months
what are you excited about that is a
really good question I think I'm going
anywhere special for the next month
which is super nice really kind of happy
it looked like I was gonna get you
nightly and then I wasn't then I wasn't
it doesn't look like I'm going so it's a
little sad but I'm sure plenty of Google
cloud people there they're gonna have a
great time I think I'm just excited to
be yet to be going to Cuba in December
great well you got yourself this week I
will be at camless in Washington DC
which is a security and data conference
and I'm looking forward to that nice
well yeah actually the thing that I will
be doing as well as I'll be getting back
into doing some more twitch streaming of
various things Oh fun have you not been
doing that I took a break in September
because it's traveling so much
let's go think clearly I'm not watching
but yeah it'll be good to get back to
that oh good I'm glad when is that
usually I do that at 9 a.m. Pacific on
Tuesdays but I'm gonna try and slow in
doing some more streams in the middle of
the week follow me on Twitter and twitch
for more details and then mark if people
want to get in touch with us or
subscribe to the podcast yes that's good
we haven't done this in a while so if
you want to grab to the podcast
everything can be found at GCP podcast
comm you can
RSS feeds the iTunes links you can find
stitcher YouTube all the stuff that's on
there
email us at hello at GCP podcast.com
yeah if you want to send us questions of
the week we actually have a form on the
bottom of the new website so if you want
to check that out I mean you can send
his emails to love emails or hit us up
on G+ or hit us up on reddit or G+
account is plus GC podcast I read it is
/ r GC focused and we are juice we
podcast on Twitter yep exactly
oh yeah if you go to the website and you
go all the way down the bottom on the
bottom left hand side in the footer
there's a forum you can go there and you
can drop in questions the week and we
check it out every week to see what
questions people are giving us what's on
people's minds great I think that's it
first for this week mark yeah so Melanie
thanks for joining me for yet another
week on the podcast thank you thank you
all for listening and we'll see you all
next week
[Music]